now's the super practical section of how
to find and choose designers we can get
through this really quickly happy to
answer questions afterwards about it but
you know the basic questions we always
get asked is you know well when when and
how the reality of it is there are so
many ways to answer this but this is
just you know super boilerplate advice
it's that preceeds seed and probably pre
a you still need a co-founder probably
to do it and then you could probably get
by with a little bit of consulting by
series a you should probably unless you
truly have nothing that has a user
facing element which is rare I mean even
developer api's today you know I would
argue that you need a developer API
designer who sort of runs through this
whole process but just for a developer
experience is incredibly valuable
that's make-or-break for you know even
highly technical products you know that
that's when you should really start
thinking about your first hire and then
you know by Series B what you really
should think about is how do you hire a
team a lot of people reach series B and
they're actually you know they're still
at the first higher stage and the
difficult part is if you actually have
1015 engineers and you're trying to hire
that first designer and you don't have
you're not going to hire a team that's
actually like a little bit of a
nightmare for a designer to work at
which makes sense actually to be the
only person on that whole team in charge
of design and you versus 20 engineers is
a very scary thing for a designer so
this might be a little outdated but this
is you know sort of what I've always
used in the past they're just websites
online to sort of find designers so it
dribbles is incredible portfolio you can
get a lot out of LinkedIn look for you
know companies in your space that have
done designed very very well and you can
just very point-blank start reaching out
to them behance crop I mean all of these
are websites and you should just go
check out AIGA even has a little
database of member designers on there
when I'm thinking about hiring people
directly for a full-time role or even
for contract there are a bunch of
schools that have worked well for me C
muh
di NYU MIT RISD Parsons Stanford this is
really not a comprehensive list and
frankly there are so many incredibly
good designers you know who have never
been to a Design School in terms of
finding consultants there's really two
paths here one is to go ahead and find
an individual so you know it turns out
that there are a lot of people who you
can kind of use this as a way to recruit
them so some of the best folks they
actually really like to work on a lot of
different projects all of the time and
you know there's actually a very large
pool of individuals for basically
individual consultants and they're hard
to get and you might have to email a lot
of them but you can reach out you can't
hire them as temp consultants and if
there's a really good fit that could be
a way to get to know them to come on
board a really cool trick that I've
heard for people who just need low cost
like logo design and visual design
there's actually an incredible number of
people out there in the world who are
not first world designers and they're
totally available on 99designs Fiverr I
think this is not you know they're
probably a bunch of other places like
that the trick that I've heard that you
could use is you can actually take your
job put it on one of these job boards
and then don't just do it for you know
one don't don't just hire one job you
could hire 20 jobs and then look at the
output of those 20 different people and
then personally befriend the person who
does some of the best work and you'll
find people in you know all around the
world Philippines Thailand Eastern
Europe everywhere real I mean Africa
Asia Europe like you know even the
United States people who are incredibly
talented who you know actually but
they're just starting out in their
careers where they don't know how to
actually get great jobs and you could be
that way too that they learn about
startups you know design firms they're
just so many you know the difficulty
with design firms is you kind of have to
find one that is willing to work with
startups and
you know many of them the bread and
butter for the best design firms truly
is working with Fortune 500 companies
for outrageous sums of money so it can
be very difficult to find ones that will
work with startups you know they get
labs is the one out of DC that I use the
most but they're you know our giant
direct directories and frankly referrals
are sort of your best bet and then I
want to call out a company that just
graduated from YC a few weeks ago called
play-doh design their URL is use
play-doh calm you should definitely
reach out to them I think that they do a
very very amazing job so how do you
actually attract a designer to work at a
start-up and you know really sort of the
ideal at Series A or even where you're
at right now is like you know if you are
a truly a consumer focused company you
kind of need a co-founder on there who
can actually run this for you but later
on especially you know and if you're a
three or four person team you can
usually find one
ideally unicorn to come join and give
them you know a much more senior role
that that'll be fairly important at
series a but once you do have a larger
team of five to ten engineers it gets
really scary for a designer who's used
to working with teams work working for a
design firm or working at you know um
via Facebook or one of the large tech
companies like they're used to sitting
with other people who spend all of their
time thinking about all of the things
that we were just talking about with
wireframes and users and personas and so
it can be incredibly scary for those
designers to come and work for you much
later stage if you don't plan to hire a
team that is diversified that you know
that you know it just gives them a
really good day-to-day you know and then
at the end of the day like being able to
be very crisp about what those roles are
that's the other part of hiring a team
that's incredibly important it's going
to be very very hard to find a unicorn
but often you can break it down by the
exact things that I mentioned like
they're incredibly good PM's who have
great resumes who have great backgrounds
who you know that's one coherent role
interaction designers sometimes they
can't make
things that are pretty but they are
incredibly empathetic they're able to
think through you know they're great
writers they're incredible communicators
and that's what you would look for in
that rule and finally visual design
that's probably the part that is that
you know oh yeah but it's often stands
on its own it doesn't have to and so
it's just a different skill set and then
really quickly I mean it's actually very
effective for startups who want to hire
design teams to actually write about it
content marketing works extremely well
social media works incredibly well and
you know if you're all engineers but
you're already thinking about this and
talking through a lot of the terms that
I was talking about well that's a
culture fit for designers because you
know that's basically what they want
they want executives or workplaces or
founders who understand and speak their
language and so that's why I encourage
you guys to be very open with do it
yourself to do it to understand these
things because even if you don't do it
in you know down the road you're
actually far better at evaluating
managing and working closely with people
who do and who are very good at it how
do you actually interview these designer
as well this is typically what I
examined you know do a quick phone
screen at the end a like it's actually
you know no matter how beautiful a
portfolio is it's just so hard to work
with people who have sort of their own
vision that cannot communicate and so
the phone screen it's really all about
you know great communication skills I
think that's incredibly essential and
then when they actually come and meet
you in the team you know actually have
them walk through the hard decisions the
trade-offs like we spend a lot of time
about product design you want to see
exactly that kind of thought about
personas about prioritization what are
the difficult trade-offs because there
always are in every type of product you
could design and finally I recommend who
whichever founder is has been doing the
design or the product you know you've
already been solving problems that you
might have so the key thing there is if
you've already spent your you know
2,000 hours thinking about a given
problem you know it's the best for you
to actually spend time walking through a
candidate over and over again and just
to make sure that you think through
these things the same way that they do
so you can read this later but you know
it's pretty straightforward you know
think about design you don't want people
who're complainers actually it's pretty
common you know you want someone who's
empathetic and listens to your needs is
you know it's usually bad for someone to
talk about themselves a lot and so you
know going back to the empathy point
that's incredibly important you know the
funniest thing that I like to use is
when someone's when I ask them a design
question if they just go to the
whiteboard and just start drawing they
fail because wait why didn't you ask
about the users who's it for what's the
problem and so you know these are just
guidelines there's so many ways to
interview you know I if you don't have a
really good design leader on your team I
highly recommend that you go to a friend
or someone who you do respect who can do
this stuff to just be like sort of a
final check before you do hire someone
so you know these are a bunch of books
that I've sort of referred to throughout
the talk this is just a starting point
this is far from comprehensive but you
know if you bought every single one of
these books and read it that you know
front to back you would be a pretty good
designer
maybe I hear a bunch of links that you
should probably read afterwards - you
know taste from makers is one of these
PG essays that you know I think not a
lot of people talk about but it's
incredibly timeless so I highly
recommend that and then these are links
that are very specific about you know
how do you write a PRD what's your first
wireframe and then these other websites
we just really really like because
there's so much there that you know this
field is incredibly deep so thank you so
much for spending and making it all the
way to the end of this talk it's an
hour-and-a-half 90 minutes we made it
through a hudner of four slides so thank
you for sitting with me I will leave you
with just one final thought and it's
truly that you know what we're talking
about with a start-up design is only one
of this three-legged stool and your
startup your startup success truly lies
at the intersection of all of these
things so thank you so much thank you
for spending time with me I know that
was a lot so the question is how
important is an about Us page I mean
yeah this isn't necessarily a design
thing I actually really think it's
important in that going back to our you
know moment where we were talking about
how alone we are as in this in this you
know sort of product Baron product
landscape you know you just feel so
alone and the about Us page is the one
place where you as founders can tell
your story like everyone is spending so
much time trying to be incredibly I mean
they're trying to imitate Microsoft
they're trying to be Google right and
you know you should embrace how powerful
it is that you're trying to do this
thing and being a real human being
answering emails and putting your name
on the website I mean I would argue that
that's why one of the big reasons why
coinbase was so successful I mean Brian
Armstrong very early on he was probably
the only person in the whole Bitcoin
world who was willing to put their name
you know the address like I mean just
basic things to make it an incredibly
real real thing so I you know I think
about us is very important for your
relationship with your customers and
that's not a design thing yes
how do you ask questions that really let
you accurately see your user there's a
lot of times you know you might be doing
a user interview and you feel like
they're not yeah so I guess the question
is how do you actually well you know how
do you properly ask questions to sort of
get the story of your user you know the
hard part here is there's not really one
way to do it I think it really does come
back to being a good interviewer and
thinking through I mean asking
open-ended questions is actually a
really good way to do it it's just you
know tell me about your day and like oh
you know tell me about you can even ah
seize on emotion because the best
problems to solve were actually
incredibly emotion emotional ones it's
like I get frustrated when blah or I get
mad when blah right like those are a lot
of very very strong you know going back
to you know I think Jeff might have
taught me this actually just purely that
um you know you really want to look for
things there you know hair on fire
problems you know things that actually
but you know get people upset you know
like emotion it can be an incredibly
powerful and good thing so open-ended
questions and look for emotion yes yeah
so first question is about prototyping
and you know the I have a confession to
make
I have not done a lot of prototyping
simply because I am I'm always in such a
rush to get the code done that the
second I know what I want to build I
just build it and then I ship it and
then I'll just do it live and so I
haven't personally gotten a lot of use
out of prototype prototyping but I know
that it's an incredibly valuable tool
and that's just a weird weird one for me
because I'm just always I would rather
just ship the thing and have
be out there yeah and then sorry the
second yeah so the question is you know
if you know a problem but you haven't
found the solution you know the hard
part there is like it's not totally
clear to me that design can solve it you
know what you describe maybe is either a
business problem or a tech not
technology problem you know it sometimes
is a design problem if there's you know
it's I don't know I mean the hard part
is these things are so squishy right
like if it's a business problem then you
don't have distribution people don't
know they have the problem you can't get
in front of them or if it's a if it's a
technology problem then it's like I mean
yeah how do we actually build the thing
and if we're not capable of doing it
then design can't solve it right how
about you just keep building things
until you get it right
do what Jeff said over here yes please
[Music]
the question is are there places where
you should maintain your distance I
can't think of any at the moment there
probably are I mean it was a really big
advantage for them to you know be out in
the open I could imagine being if it's a
incredibly competitive and if you want
to be secretive there are cases where
you don't want to be that open and that
does happen especially for you know
something that's easily copied or
something that you know is incredibly
enterprise focus so it's not important
for a lot of people to know about it
those are the main scenarios where I
think secrecy turns out to be very
important but most people tend to err on
the side of more secrets secrecy than
less you know the standard YC ISM around
this that I very much believe
you know whenever you're creating
something new you're not competing
against all of the other people out
there you're only competing against
obscurity you're you're competing
against like the back button and so to
the extent that that's true being as
open as possible getting as many people
to know about you as possible and being
a human being and having that interplay
that's really good
question is god is controversy I mean it
depends on the type of a controversy you
know one of the funniest examples of me
giving very bad advice and me very being
very relieved that the founder did not
take that advice was a company called
Soylent so they came in through YC they
were working on something totally
different in networking equipment and I
sat down with them in this room for
office hours and they said great news we
have this incredible we have you know
all of these orders people love this
thing oh by the way we're gonna stick
with the name Soylent and I said please
please don't call it that do you know
what that means haven't you seen the
movie and it turns out that you know the
entire reason why they were able to get
probably a billion dollars worth of
earned you know free advertising the
reason why they have an incredibly
powerful business today is purely
because they found exactly the right
kind of controversy 90% of people who
love food hear about it and say this is
terrible I hate it in fact they hate it
so much there at dinner and their top
telling everyone they know about it and
then ten percent of people hear about it
and they're like oh my god I need that
now so there are cases where controversy
can be incredibly powerful
they're sorry thank you guys
you